salut mort ok non c'est robbie robin que
me batman et robin non udo comment vous
avez fait pour la garde de la petite à
bas j'ai démissionné je sais pas ce qui
est génial un travail donc toi aussi tu
avais un travail non oui j'avais un
travail mais enfin tu vois ce que tu
veux dire
j'avais un drame c'est un vrai travail
donc moi je joue papa il a démissionné
qui cette compression des systèmes parce
que pour la craie sur my shop c'est ça
et et mao on occupe et ludo et moi je
peux pas gérer un bébé serait même pas
capable de s'occuper de bobigny a non
non c'est robbie mais je ferai pas prête
tout cela parce que c'est un animal
innocent
[Applaudissements]
eux peuvent aller elle après comment
robbie rêver quand on comprend tout un
ensuite on fera les petites balades
d'accord on finit le paquet d'affaires à
les élever des banques
maintenant y'a plus rien le regardes tu
vide assez sec tu veux aller un petit
choc pour le dessert de me robin du
prochain robbie bien voir comment ils
travaillent pas
robbie
pro b
et c'est pas sérieux j'ai cru que tu es
mort tu m'as fait peur j'ai mal au
ventre mais tu parle rugby à ix
tu as vu de ce que ta bouffe est aussi
oui mais moi j'aime être hommage et
c'est ce que je préfère au monde
il est tout vomi en effet je peux avoir
des croquettes
ben non non non les plus rien et c'est
fini c'est pas grave tu mangeras demain
tombe est pas pour ça oui
non mais c'est pas pour ça que je suis
triste pour couleurs hardies je
m'appelle robbie sais pas je vous fais
c'est là en fait le vrai problème c'est
pas ça c'est du dos et jadis il
m'acheter un collier
il m'a jetée de balle il m'a aussi
acheter le poulet qui coule et tu vois
c'est que c'est le mort et queen c'est
cool c'est non et ce un peu avec tous
les deux vu est sympa mais le problème
c'est qu'il n'aime pas jouer avec moi du
coup je joue tout seul
elle joue à la baballe tout seul c'est
nul cobra
je comprends est d'ailleurs c'est même
pas possible le fait maintenant
eh bien non
[Musique]
allez stop les bennes bon ok je t'ai
tâche mais pas d'entourloupe un tu vas
chercher tu reviens là s'amuse la halle
et moraux bis allée j buts autrichiens
là bas ils sont trop cool et ils m'ont
pris mon bateau j'ai peu joué avec eux
oui mais si tu veux on y va aller là-bas
non non en fait je veux dire on va jouer
à des jeux de chiens oui bah non non non
mais je comprends et les copains mais je
peux jouer avec vous je suis dans le
coin
[Musique]
à
ah ah
ouais
robbie
vos billets
ob yuko